hoy en eeuu se celebra el
246 aniversario de la independencia y
pocas veces los estadounidenses han
estado tan divididos parece que la
democracia estadounidense sigue luchando
por su supervivencia todo esto mientras
la comisión de la cámara de
representantes que investiga el ataque
al capitolio el pasado 6 de enero 1.021
revela detalles del intento de donald
trump de no reconocer las elecciones del
año 2020 todo parece indicar que el ex
presidente está impaciente por lanzar su
campaña para el 2024 entretanto la corte
suprema- despojo a millones de mujeres
del derecho constitucional a interrumpir
el embarazo limitó la lucha contra el
cambio climático y amplió el derecho al
porte de armas las tensiones sociales se
ven acentuadas por represión económica
tras la guerra en ucrania que está
encareciendo los alimentos y también la
gasolina a precios récord esto se suma a
la delincuencia con armas de fuego los
tiroteos masivos que acaban con la vida
de miles de personas cada año que los
datos revelan además que esto va en
aumento
para ello entonces quiero saludar en ese
momento a nuestro segundo invitado el
día rafael peñalver analista político y
abogado constitucionalista de eeuu
raphael buen día gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
hablemos del balance general cómo llega
la sociedad estadounidense a este 4 de
julio
round buenos días y gracias por
invitarme a tu programa estamos hoy
celebrando el 4 de julio el país
enfrentando nuevos retos y algunos de
los retos en sus instituciones más
básicas la corte suprema después de
estas decisiones de la última semana
encuentra se encuentra en una posición
donde tienes menos apoyo popular que
nunca en su historia el congreso de los
eeuu con las pistas con respecto a lo
que ocurrió el 6 el 6 de junio y el 6 de
enero y el país pues esperando las
elecciones de noviembre con gran
incertidumbre sobre lo que va a pasar sí
que es una situación difícil para eeuu
en el medio de una guerra en ucrania que
que se está con ghana amenazando
involucrar cada vez más a los países
occidentales y en el medio de una
inflación así que el 4 de julio se
celebra con una renovación de esos
principios que dieron en la razón gran
acción norteamericana pero con gran con
gran dudas sobre el futuro del país
además hablemos de uno de los puntos son
más importantes que vimos estos últimos
días rafael y fue la derogación del
aborto la eliminación del histórico
fallo roe versus wade que después
apoyaba a las mujeres o mejor dicho les
daba la facilidad del aborto a niveles
federal con una corte suprema y
conservadora no usted lo decía esta
corte suprema pues por lo que se ven las
calles no tendría el apoyo popular pero
finalmente ellos son quienes tienen la
última palabra que tanto puede presionar
el pueblo estadounidense a una corte
conservadora que puedes es vitalicia y
no cambia hasta que renuncie o hasta que
uno fuese pues se muera tú lo has dicho
raúl una corte que tiene la última
palabra pero no tiene poder el único
poder que tiene es el poder del
prestigio del creer al poder ciudadano
si tú eres la constitución
norteamericana la corte suprema tiene
muy poco poder en sí no tiene
presupuesto no tienen sus soldados para
poder para que se que se cumplan sus
órdenes
en la buena fe en que todo el pueblo
norteamericano siempre ha dicho la corte
suprema con una corte a política y ahí
tienes un poder el poder del prestigio
eso se está perdiendo rápidamente la
forma en que fueron impuestos los
últimos tres jueces por el presidente de
trump después de que se le negara al
presidente obama la nominación del juez
garland porque decían que era la que se
había nominado en el último año de la
presidencia de obama y por lo tanto no
se podía considerar y entonces cuando
muere la juez que instruía
inmediatamente trompa aprovecha con sólo
30 días quedando de su término impone
una nueva jueza a la corte suprema esto
ha creado gran duda sobre la legitimidad
de la corte suprema y te repito es algo
básico para la democracia norteamericana
esta democracia un país que tiene tanto
poder nuclear tantas fortalezas sin
embargo su sistema político es franklin
muy frágil y depende en gran parte de
las instituciones
y la fe que tenga los ciudadanos hacia
esas instituciones en particular la
corte suprema de los desahucios raffaele
cómo están las cosas no cree que también
en parte el problema sea con una
constitución tan antigua como la es como
es la de la de eeuu no se plantea en ese
país digamos algún tipo de cambio en la
constitución
eso es inviable es imposible no se puede
se puede hacer
el gran problema es que la construcción
americana para para hacer cambios es un
proceso difícil tú puedes hacer un
cambio radical que sería convocar una
nueva constituyente una una reunión para
para para ver todos los capítulos de la
constitución pero eso abriría una caja
de pandora eso nos está contemplando en
serio en este momento se están
contemplando otros cambios por ejemplo
que los términos de los jueces no sean
vitalicios que se le permita a cada
presidente nominar para mantener algún
tipo de balance ideológico en la fe en
la corte en este momento todo cuando se
muera o cuando se retire un juez y de
acuerdo con eso el presidente del
momento nómina a un candidato pero
cuando ese sistema se dio lógica cuando
se le negó presidente obama nominará el
juez que ley que le correspondía a él
durante su término y después viene un
presidente en trono e impone al último
minuto una juez que cambia totalmente el
balance ideológico ese tipo de al uso
del poder es el que está contaminando el
prestigio de la corte y el que hace que
los ciudadanos cada vez tengan menos fe
que la corte suprema sea una una entidad
judicial y no simplemente otra entidad
política más claro y además de las
decisiones de la corte suprema pues
finalmente afecta es a los ciudadanos y
a todo el conglomerado
estadounidense también recordemos que en
los últimos días la corte suprema le
dijo no a más recursos para combatir el
cambio climático algo que pues nos está
afectando a todos también como esto
impacta a la sociedad estadounidense y
como eso también trunca de alguna manera
los planes de campaña del presidente y
la agenda política del presidente joe
biden
exactamente porque al tener el planner
bailén se encuentra que está en el medio
durante una tirantez enorme dentro de la
propia corte suprema dos visto algo que
nunca se había visto anteriormente que
es unos jueces hablando en una forma
dura y quick y una forma de que no se
que no es una forma de normalmente
judicial unos contra los otros la forma
en que la corte suprema- abolió el
derecho del aborto no simplemente fue la
abolición del aborto sino que habló en
una forma repito de octubre a una forma
cruda sobre los jueces que adoptaron esa
decisión hace más de 50 años bailén se
encuentra presionado por la izquierda de
su partido para que sea aún más activo
en promover cambios más drásticos en la
corte suprema y por otra parte no tiene
los votos para poder hacer eso en su
templo de su propio partido se habla sin
vaivén para poder mantener la mayoría en
la cámara de representantes y si los
republicanos toman el poder la cámara y
una mayoría en el senado pues cualquier
cosa puede pasar se pueden imponer
cambios como por ejemplo el cambian de
estructura de que hagan falta 60 votos
para pasar un cambio una ley en el
senado simplemente se pide que si los
republicanos tienen la mayoría que se se
olviden de esas reglas tradicionales del
senado y que simplemente se haga un 1
que se pase la legislación por mayoría
en el senado eso canarias o traería
cambios irreversibles en el país